Twizzler eaters
kill yourself
hi I'm Seth Rogan yo what's up this Ice
Cube and these are our favorite snacks
[Music]
what okay ketchup so
these are ketchup potato chips which are
only available in Canada these are what
I grew up eating and are my favorite
chip and I know they don't have them in
America and Americans have the weirdest
reaction to these chips in that they act
as though the combination of ketchup and
potato is like [__] insane they're
like [__] ketchup potato chips what
the [__] are you [__] nuts as though
the most normal thing to put on a fried
potato in the world is not [__]
ketchup
what the hell is going on here well
what's also funny is they taste nothing
like ketchup
oh man it smells like an old bag of
french fries
[Music]
um
I was hoping for more than that Cube
the Ultimate Burger
in California is the fat burger you
reference Fatburger right lyrically yes
you know how do you have serenaded
I said it's two in the morning got the
fattest so what's your what's the order
it's just cheese well this one is pretty
pretty plain you know I mean this is
like pretty ghetto yeah but but you know
I would I would have a a king Burger you
know what I'm saying Mayo a little
mustard but that's how I'll put an egg
on there whoa you know what I mean and
probably top it with some chili wow kill
it I would kill this you're eating that
in under 90 seconds we can eat these
[Music]
my Burger's great we don't have it in
Canada but as soon as I move to L.A I
started eating this and I would go hang
out I would go to that Fatburger in
Santa Monica play tonight sometimes and
it's wild over there you would hang out
without getting a Fatburger I just go
people watch hang out at Fatburger
parking lots a fat burger parking lot
pimp right here just hanging out just
taking it in
in Canada they call craft macaroni and
cheese for some insane reason crap
dinner what so that is going on in
Canada
where's the fun at in Canada like
it was just fun to say
hey we cried the dinner feels a little
standard it feels a little lazy yeah to
the point that they they abbreviated it
to KD I mean you know for all those
that's hit okay no you know I mean it's
like you know Mom can I have some of
that KD tonight you know what I mean
this it's just craft macaroni and cheese
it's exactly the same and it's really
good do you like Kraft Packers I love it
I mean you can't fault bad packaging but
the ingredients
do you ever add [__] to it
I'm not in prison only prisoners like
and crazy stuff into stuff now but I
love making sure it's the best yeah it's
[__] good I still eat that [__] yeah
Twizzler eaters
kill yourself
Superior liftership Red Vines that'll be
the best marketing campaign for the Red
Vines ever yeah Twizzler eaters kill
yourself please Red Vines
let's do it
why are these good Twizzlers terrible
these are sweet and delicious
and because there's quizzes are wax
it's like eating a candle if you go see
a movie is this what you're buying of
course I'm buying this over popcorn I'm
buying this over if you do you like
black peppers black licorice are from
the Devil
oh yeah
yes now I would argue there was like
maybe when I was in high school I
essentially only ate microwavable
burritos like yeah I my parents would go
to Costco by
hundreds of them and every day I ate
like four of them this is like a
7-Eleven yep you know I mean when you
really like looking for that black tie
delectable yeah it's a high-end meal
good meals you know especially we're
just missing that school taco sauce
sometimes I would I would bring a bag of
my own like taco chips from home and I
would steal the nacho cheese from
Central
that's a good one
let's see what we got here
[__] up
just like your mama used to try to make
not bad bro not bad I don't need to I
need that school taco sauce yeah but
bean and cheese is awesome
[Music]
what
these are heavy yeah see compared to the
chips have some real masks in them right
off the bat you know this you can eat
this like as a three-course meal you
know I mean if you you miss lunch this
could be your lunch I mean who couldn't
fall in love with a with a Cheeto puff
of cheese like this what do they
actually call this what is it when they
don't have the the flavor on it yeah
what are these actually called you
imagine a powderless Cheeto
oh man that's the worst site
that's an ungodly image
so a neutral Cheeto
um
that's [__] good ain't it
what's up to your homeboy Ice Cube I'm
with my homie Chef Rogan and you just
checked us out on snack go see Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem in
theaters right now right now
right now and don't make me have to come
see you man bring my homie Superfly with
me
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]